well Brian Holocaust Survivors went
through the unimaginable but for many
the pain they live with is something
that will never Escape them 8 news now
reporter Victoria Saha brings us the
story of a Survivor who lives in Las
Vegas he was recently awarded the
highest honor from Germany for his work
to keep the stories of the Holocaust
alive
number
41212 the only identity Ben lesser had
while living in persecution what we went
through there is Hell on Earth 94 year
old lesser is largely known for his work
as a holocaust Survivor but before that
haunting time in history lesser was just
a young boy growing up in Poland what do
you remember the most about your mom
[Music]
and his dad a chocolate factory owner
every child's dream right us kids will
search his pockets because we climbed
some some sweets at 10 years old his
suite life of Innocence quickly Stripped
Away as the Nazis invaded Poland running
into our apartment
pistols ripping us we were still in bed
curfews were set and resources became
limited if you disobeyed any of these
ordinances there was only one punishment
to shout you with the situation becoming
tense lesser's parents made arrangements
to escape to Hungary in a cold truck
with a family of seven lesser and his
brother went first his parents were
supposed to go a few days later I've
been in the truck with my little brother
be hugged we said goodbye it would be
the last time he hugged his parents as
someone called the Gestapo on them and
everyone was shot Lester and his
siblings were sent to a labor camp known
as Auschwitz I let go of my sister and
my little brother never to see each
other again
they went straight to the gas Chambers
then came what is known as the Death
March and then the death trained to
Dachau Germany lesser one of 18 people
out of 5 000 who survived no water no
food three weeks everybody is dead
lesser's will to live allowed him to see
Liberation day we see the inmates are
are around are on their hands and knees
catching the boots from the American GI
they look like Gods to us a day where
number four one two one two became Ben
lesser again from that point this story
just begins lesser and his older sister
Lola were the only ones in his family to
survive
is your forgiveness in your heart
for everything that you've been through
I cannot forgive the perpetrators of the
Holocaust no how can you deliver this
slaughtered six million of us nearly 80
years after the Holocaust lesser
continues to be the voice for the
millions who were silenced I don't know
how I survived this lesser wrote a book
on his survival and just a few weeks ago
he was given the order of marriage cross
from Germany one of the highest honors
the country can give an individual it
means so much to me and lesser has a
message for the living Generations Free
Speech should not include hate speech
Germans today
and I don't blame their children or
their grandchildren
it's not their fault
[Music]
keep in mind in southern Nevada there
are currently about 60 living Holocaust
Survivors